For centuries the shadow of hypnosis belief as a cure or amusement tool, however
The prevailing reputation was false and ambiguous. So what does science say?
Is hypnosis a fact?
For a moment, close your eyes and imagine a lemon. Imagine the smell of those lemons,
Imagine its color and shape. Imagine the feel of the lemon and feel the touch of your skin. Now take it
Slowly and slowly cut her, and brought out her juice. Take a slice of it
And put them in your mouth. Now open your eyes.
Do you have saliva? It is seen, regardless of its being presented in the media as a form
Control of the mind, researchers describe hypnosis differently. Hypnosis is a state of
Awareness requires high attention and a center that reduces the appearance of competing ideas
Allows enhanced ability to respond to suggestions. So hypnosis is from a scientific point of view
The type of focus your brain feels when you read or read a book
A television program while the rest of the world seems far away, "a metaphor for your intense focus on seeing or reading and separating from the world"
The research also showed that hypnosis is a fact that can disrupt our spontaneous response
Such as reading the words directly in front of us. In this test, try pronouncing the color name
The name on the screen is not "Tested". In this case you will say that the color is "blue"
As fast as you can, try it yourself. This is deceptive, is not it? This is known as the strobe effect.
It is difficult because the automatic process of wanting to read words has stumbled our ability
On the color label quickly. On each if the words in another language such as
Dutch You will not have a problem naming the color because the words have no meaning in your mind
..But if you speak Dutch
In one study the hypnotic participants experimented with a strobe test after being told
They will see vague and meaningless words. As a result, Strobe's effect is temporarily suspended
Participants were able to call the color without errors or delay. When this test was conducted
Using MRI, participants showed lower activity in the frontal cortex
An area in the brain involved in solving contradictions and competitive requirements in addition to
Decrease in the visual cortex, which is an important area to distinguish words
The Harvard Group Measure for Hypnosis Sensitivity showed that the process of hypnosis is distributed
In a natural gypsy curve. Very few people did not feel anything during hypnosis, the number of people
Respond to the feelings and intellectual movements and suggestions of guidance, such as raise your hands involuntarily
A few of them responded to cognitive suggestions that affect memory
Perception and were able to create hallucinations and memory loss
You can also change the pain. In a study during hypnosis
The participants were given a painful thermal stimulus on their right hands and asked them to assess their pain.
They were then told that they would give the same heat catalyst as the new catalyst at a painless temperature
They were asked to assess their pain and assessed it with their first assessment. In truth it is their minds that have shown them
Same level of activity in frontal cortex.
Scientists have also examined the brains of people who falsely call leg palsy as if they are magnetically hypnotized
Their brains were later examined again after hypnotizing them to find an increase in brain activity
In the right region of the dorsal frontal cortex and in the right cerebellum and in the left area of ​​the thalamus and in the stump
People who claim to have false leg palsy did not show any change in their brain regions. This suggests that hypnosis is another neurotic basis
For those who are wrestling with him.
If many hypnotic hypnotists may be hypnotizing, under the brain scan
Where it clearly shows who lies and who is hypnotically hypnotized.
If you want our vision hypnotized by a professional first time watch
Our video is broken on AsapTHOUGHT where we actually do it! It was an interesting experience!
Click on the screen or click on the link in the description box.
Join our channel to see more weekly science videos!